[Musique]
dick rivers est un des piliers du rock
français
il laisse dans le deuil en admirateur de
longue date qui est aussi devenu un ami
tu fait très triste quand j'ai su que je
vois pas dit on se parlait à tout les 24
200 me battrai mais cette année j'ai
trouvé pour comme de ce décret blues est
un enfant de l'après-guerre très jeune
le chanteur originaire de nice ne jure
que par elvis presley né hervé forneri
le musicien adoptera le nom de scène des
creuses inspiré par le nom de personnage
joué au cinéma justement par elvis
presley à l'âge de 16 ans il enregistre
ses premières chansons avec son groupe
ni chat sauvage mais c'est hier son
premier avec les chats sauvages
c'était c'est pas sérieux c'est pas
sérieux monde vous pour lebouc j'entends
comme ça dans la jungle des igloos
avec sa coupe banane et sa voix de
crooner la carrière solo de décrire buzz
prend son envol dans les années 60
bassett jan chan parmi tous ces succès
la chanson viens me faire oublier tourne
en boucle à la radio ville peut faire
oublier
quarante ans
toi chez aimé
cette discographie compte une trentaine
d'albums et tout au long de sa carrière
découvrir et souvent venue chanter au
québec
dick a toujours eu un attachement au
québec depuis 1965 c'est pas compliqué
il ya toujours adoré venir au québec fiq
écoutez vous en avez rencontré vraiment
beaucoup beaucoup des missiles jusqu'à
la fin de sa vie dick rivers est monté
sur scène toujours animé par le rock n
roll qu'il nous quitte le jour de ses 74
ans paul daraîche garde d'excellents
souvenirs de cet éternel rockeur qu'il y
avait un site pour que nos impôts ici
oui j'ai depuis mai radio-canada mourir
[Musique]
sa femme mais c'est quand même